you know we always have heard like uh in
certain cities the checking in thing and
obviously he's gone viral and he's got
his check-in website which is a great
marketing idea [ __ ] love it you get a
certificate on it yeah but like in terms
of like um
do you think that's something that's
important if someone comes to LA
I have to tap in with like certain
aspects that's important anywhere you're
at right no like like how does the same
how's the saying go one of the oldest
things right when in Rome
you do as Romans do you feel me that's
that's my thing is is like I always you
know it depends but it's a figure if
you're a street rapper exactly yes let's
say you could be you could be from
Chicago absolutely and if you move as
like a a street rapper you you claim to
be from the streets yeah it's probably
smart for you too hell yeah
that's what you're gonna attract because
if you're like a pop artist yeah you
come to L.A yeah do your [ __ ] do your
thing wow yeah you might get robbed but
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah but
wasn't nobody gonna defend you anyways
at that point it's like you know it's
like I feel like I do feel like if
you're if you represent that if you're
bringing that energy then yeah you
should you gotta and that's wherever you
go right everyone have some homies where
everywhere oh yeah [ __ ] hell yeah it's
it's it's it's just Safety First you
know what I'm saying why wouldn't you
like why why not why not pay homage and
and want to meet the people where you're
where you're coming to you know what I'm
saying why not meet the locals you know
what I'm saying and learn the rules of
the land dog at the end of the day it's
only going to benefit you and get more
love if anything yeah you know what I'm
saying so yeah it's important I think
it's table manners you know where
everywhere you go you gotta have table
manners though you got to present
yourself well